Как выбрать семь книг которые изменят
вашу жизнь сегодня я хотел бы с вами
поговорить об этом Потому что я
специально сделал сегодня подборку семи
книг в различных направлениях которые
должен прочитать каждый Итак начнём с
того почему важно читать и нужно читать
книги прежде всего э Когда речь идёт о
книгах обычно книги сравнивают Что
эффективнее книги видео или аудио так
вот я вам скажу Из своего опыта что
чтение книг гораздо эффективнее чем
просмотр YouTube видео или аудио в
каком-нибудь подкасте почему это
происходит Дело в том что когда вы
читаете книги ваш мозг вынужден работать
потому что слова которые напечатанные в
книге это по сути коды которые ваш мозг
должен
дешифровал То есть когда вы смотрите на
книгу Там же нету образов там какие-то
непонятные знаки так ваш мозг эти знаки
должен конвертировать в образы так вот
это сама э работа конвертации знаков в
образы а она уже даёт нагрузку на мозг и
благодаря этому а мозг лучше усваивает
потому что он сам создаёт эти картинки
поэтому во время чтения любой книги ваш
мозг активно работает а во время
просмотра видео мозгу нет необходимости
создавать картинки и создавать образ Вы
из видео получаете готовые образы и их
запомнить гораздо сложнее Я не говорю
уже про аудио Я помню одно исследование
где говорило что мы почти 80% информации
из внешнего мира получаем за счёт
наших нашего зрения и только всё
остальное - это слух тактильный запах и
так далее Поэтому вот можете сразу
сравнить Почему
аудио гораздо менее эффективно чем видео
Не говоря уже про книги книги - Это
самый эффективный и самый лучший способ
понимания и усвоения а новых знаний
второй очень важный вопрос до того как
вы перейдёте к чтению любой литературы
или любой книги нужно ответить на вопрос
что нужно читать что нужно читать - это
на самом деле большой вопрос потому что
многие люди гордятся тем что читают всё
или читает очень много на самом деле
читать Вы должны только то что решает
вашу проблему на данный момент если у
вас какая-то проблема читайте всё по
этой проблеме Вот например когда у меня
какой-то затык или А проблема Я могу
читать семь-восемь книг одновременно и
мне задают вопрос Как вы можете
семь-восемь книг читать это же в голове
можно запутаться Нет я беру тему которая
меня волнует и из этих семи-восьми книг
выбираю только те главы которые в
которых говорится про эту тему таким
образом как бы получается что я читаю
семь-восемь книг параллельно Но на самом
деле я читаю всего по одной теме поэтому
читайте только те книги которые решают
вашу текущую
зде Вы можете у меня спросить а как же
художественная литература или другие
книги так вот я скажу Если у вас нету
острой насущной проблемы или вашей
проблемы потребностью сейчас является
отдохнуть развить ваше творческое
воображение или просто провести как-то
время вы можете взять художественную
литературу но этоже тоже вы читаете на
злобу дня есть Нелю книгу ски вяли про у
вас сейчас потребность отдохнуть Ну вот
Возьмите книгу при чтении которой вы
отдыхаете Или Возьмите книгу при чтении
которой вы размышляете но всегда чётко
Ответьте на себе на вопрос Зачем вам
нужно прочесть какую-то книгу поэтому
второй вопрос что нужно читать очень
важен третий вопрос как нужно читать
книги Дело в том что книги не надо
читать просто так как вот знаете как
ходьба вот я научился я хожу и не думаю
как книги надо читать целенаправленно
нужно понимать Для чего вы читаете и
нужно понимать как их правильно читать
чтобы усваивать потому что у нас же нет
цели прочитать книгу и поставить на
полку и забыть всё о чём мы прочитали у
нас же есть цель из этой книги извлечь
максимум пользы Поэтому если вы хотите
узнать как правильно читать книги у меня
на канале есть видео Которая так и
называется как правильно читать книги и
какие книги читать правильно вот
посмотрите это два видео Эти два видео и
вы получите ответы на свои вопросы
Ставьте лайк под этим видео И слушайте
внимательно дальше Давайте теперь
вернёмся к тому Какие же эти семь книг
которые необходимо прочесть или
обязательно прочесть каждому в своей
жизни я сделал подборку по определённым
направлениям Я всегда говорю Так что
надо во-первых читать книги которые
решают вашу проблему или помогает вам
развиваться в каком-то направлении Это
первый блок второй блок нужно всегда
читать книги которые соответствуют
уровню вашего развития потому что
например если вы начинающий бизнесмен
для вас это одни книги Если вы
продвинутый бизнесмен для Вас надо
совсем другие книги поэтому Читайте
книги соответствующие вашему уровню
развития и третье Читайте книги по
направлениям вот сегодня я для вас
сделал классику своей подборки по
направлениям для бизнесменов всех
уровней или не только для бизнесменов
для всех людей которые они должны
прочитать первая книга она связана с
межличностным общением или с общением
между людьми и это книга которую я
считаю классикой и с которой вообще
началось моё саморазвитие это книга
которая когда-то в восемьдесят девятом
году по-моему когда я был в Москве я
пошёл в МГУ на лекцию одного профессора
и на выходе из МГУ Я какой-то бабки на
таком столике увидел эту книгу в
коричневом переплёте была книга
называлась
как завоёвывать друзей и оказывать
влияние на людей автор этой книги был
Дейл Карнеги и эта книга произвела на
меня такое неизгладимое впечатление и
правилами из этой книги Кстати я
пользуюсь до сих пор эту книгу считаю
это должна быть Настольная книга любого
человека кто хочет достичь хоть каких-то
успехов в этой жизни вторая Книга - это
книга связанная с финансами это
необычный или другой взгляд на финансы с
точки зрения начина Ну в принципе она
подойдёт не только начинающим важно на
финансы смотреть не только с точки
зрения бухгалтерии и сухих цифр а
смотреть на них чуть-чуть под другим
углом и здесь бы я я бы порекомендовал
книгу Роберта ки асаки Богатый папа
бедный папа но это уже классика многие
наверное даже её и читали эта книга
очень важна потому что
она на самом деле книга не только даже о
финансах а о другом мышлении о другом
способе мышления и другом взгляде на
финансовое благополучие третья Книга -
это книга связанная с принятием решений
это очень классная книга автор её Денил
канеман она называется Думай медленно
решай быстро в этой книге Нил
канеман обсуждает две системы мышления
быструю систему и медленную систему а он
обсуждает как эти две системы
взаимодействуют и как они оказывают
влияние на принимаемые нами решения
также в этой книге Нил рассказывает и
делает глубокий анализ того А вообще как
устроена система принятия решений в
нашей голове Какие существует у нас
искажение И как мы сами себя обманываем
во многих случаях четвёртая книга
которую я бы порекомендовал она по
направлению а умения продавать умение
продавать - это очень важное качество
которое и умение которое должен иметь в
сегодняшнем мире каждый человек И когда
я говорю про умение продавать это не про
умение продавать товары не про то чтобы
делать бизнес это вообще про умение
аргументировать убеждать других людей
это продавать свои идеи продавать свои
предложения это могут быть и товары и
услуги и так далее даже себя надо уметь
продавать когда вы устраиваетесь на
работу Вы на самом деле же себя продаёте
когда вы знакомитесь с девушкой или
девушка знакомится с парнем Вы же по
сути себя продаёте То есть вы презентует
стороны так вот книга Джо жирар
Как продавать что угодно Кому угодно Я
считаю это тоже классика сам Джо жирар
он такой был продавец автомобилей и он
был лучшим и он даже попал в книгу
рекордов Гиннеса с точки зрения продаж И
он рассказывает про важность
взаимодействия про важность умения
слушать про то как общаться Как отвечать
на возражения и так далее и так далее В
общем эта книга Я считаю будет супер
полезна каждому из вас Наверняка у вас
тоже есть любимые ни книги и По этим
направлениям Напишите в комментариях мне
будет интересно прочитать Да и другим
зрителям тоже будет интересно почитать
По этим направлениям Какие ещё есть
хорошие книги которые вы прочитали пятое
направление - это
искусство сторителлинга сторителлинг -
это новое слово которое пришло с
английского языка на русский язык
переводится как умение рассказывать
истории Если говорить о сторителлинг то
одной из лучших книг в области истории
является книга искусство сторителлинга
авторство джонатана гола очень хорошая
книга почему сторителлинг очень важен
потому что сторителлинг - это самый
лучший способ обучать кому-то кого-то
раз это самый лучший способ доносить
свои идеи до других людей и третье - это
самый лучший способ продавать что-либо
ещё Это самый лучший способ убеждать
когото кого-то в чём-либо поэтому
научитесь правильному Телин и у вас
пойдут кардинальные изменения в вашей
жизни Вы научитесь убеждать Вы научитесь
продавать Вы научитесь продвигать ваши
идеи люди не любят сухое выступление
люди любят слушать истории потому что
эволюционно с древних времён все знания
человечества передавались либо путём игр
Вы знаете что дети постоянно играют либо
в виде сторителлинга рассказов которые
древние мудрецы или старики рассказывали
молодёжи у костра сидя вечером и кушая
стейк из мамонта шестая книга которую я
хотел бы вам рекомендовать это книга
связанная с привычками вы знаете
привычки очень важны в нашей жизни
учёные даже провели исследование где
доказали что почти
92% по-моему всех наших действий в
течение дня мы делаем на основе привычек
так вот Представьте что вы живёте 100
лет из которых 92 года Вы действуете по
привычке так получается что-то тако ваша
жизнь оказывается ваша жизнь - это есть
набор привычек поэтому очень важно
избавляться от плохих привычек не
эффективных привычек и внедрять в вашу
жизнь эффективные новые хорошие
эффективные привычки Поэтому я считаю
лучшая
книга связанная с привычками и о том как
их развивать это книга Чарльза Дага сила
привычки обязательно почитайте эту книгу
и начните День за днём внедрять хорошие
полезные эффективные привычки в свою
жизнь Причём здесь я сразу дам лайфхак с
плохими привычками лучше не бороться это
бесполезно у плохих привычек огромная
сила самое лучшее что вы можете сделать
это выбрать одну хорошую полезную
эффективную привычку направить всё
внимание на внедрение этой привычки и
благодаря тому что вы будете направлять
внимание на внедрение хорошей привычки
одна плохая привычка у вас будет отпада
то есть с плохими привычками не надо
бороться надо всю энергию направлять на
внедрение хорошей привычки и благодаря
этому из-за недостатка внимания плохая
привычка у вас будет сама по себе
отваливаться Конечно я читаю очень много
новых книг появляется очень много
интересных новых книг но вот эти семь
книг являются классикой которые должен
прочитать каждый Но если Вас интересуют
новые книги или Новые лайфхаки
подписывайтесь на мой Telegram канал
ссылочку я оставляю внизу и седьмая
книга которую я конечно не могу обойти
вниманием И не могу не рекомендовать это
книга связанная с эффективностью
планированием и вопросами счастья это то
что сегодня наиболее актуально вообще по
исследованиям одного а крупного
инвестиционного фонда хж фонда HF своим
исследования утверждает что самый
большой тренд последних лет это даже
мегатренд - это ментальное благополучие
К сожалению с обретением экономического
финансового благополучия человечество
сталкивается с ментальными проблемами вы
сами наверное замечали вокруг у себя в
окружении сегодня очень много
расстройств сегодня очень много
психических расстройств и у детей и у
взрослых люди теряют цели а идеология в
наших странах просела в странах нету
идеологии и люди к сожалению теряются и
не могут найти себя в этой жизни поэтому
книга посвящённая счастью эффективности
и планированию лучшая книга в этой сфере
это же Конечно же моя Книга Миссия
выполнимая технология счастливой жизни
это конечно звучит нескромно Но с другой
стороны стал бы я её писать если бы я
считал что она не лучшая или есть что-то
лучше этой книги поэтому обязательно
рекомендую к прочтению свою книгу миссия
выполнима технология счастливой жизни